اتحاد مخصص ليوسوبوف دامير
قاسيموفيتش لقائد الطائرة
الخطوط الجوية الأورال
منطقة سفيردلوفسك
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
مرحبا عزيزي فلاديمير
فلاديميروفيتش
وكلهم يقدمون شرفًا عظيمًا
أن أكون هنا اليوم في الكرملين وفي
هذا الجو المهيب لتلقي
وسام كبير من يد رئيس الجمهورية
الاتحاد الروسي
هذه الجائزة ليست فقط ميزة
الاعتراف بالإجراءات المنسقة للجميع
طاقمنا وشكرا على العمل
كل الذين علمونا هذا العمل ، أنا
أنا فخور جدا وملهم
لخدمة حياتنا بشكل أكبر
شاكرين لوالدينا سبحانه وتعالى
لأحبائنا على دعمكم
شكرا
مرزين في جورجي الكسندروفيتش
مساعد طيار الطائرة
الخطوط الجوية الأورال
منطقة سفيردلوفسك
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
عزيزي فلاديمير فلاديميروفيتش
إنه لشرف عظيم لي أن أحصل على اللقب
بطل روسيا
مثل هذا التقدير العالي لعملنا في
سأستمر في تحسين بلدي
المهارات المهنية وتقديمها
سلامة الطيران شكرا لك
لك الأقارب والزملاء
[تصفيق]